parents beware some of the studios
making animated kid flicks these days
seem bent on brainwashing your children
into believing that every bad guy has a
good guy inside of just straining to
break free now take the recent film
Megamind its protagonist found that
world domination was emotionally
unsatisfying and he went full superhero
but the biggest promoter of this
contemptible moral relevancy is the CG
franchise Despicable Me in the first
installment of all big-nose evildoer
with a Russian accent abandons his plan
to control the universe when he's
transformed by the love of orphans and
cotton candy that's all it takes maybe
James Bond should have bought his
nemesis Blofeld tickets to Six Flags
instead of you know sabotaging his
rocket facility in the new sequel
Despicable Me 2 this same not so super
villain joins the anti-villain league to
help them take down one of his own kind
at best this is moral relativity that
will lull our children into a false
sense of security but I think there's
something far more nefarious going on
here
think about it what better way for a
super villain to take over the world
than by tricking a generation into
believing that he really has a heart of
gold I'm not some sort of obsessive
conspiracy theorist but have you ever
noticed that we never see Victor Von
Doom and Jeffrey Katzenberg in the same
room together is it really that
far-fetched to think that all Hollywood
movie execs are secretly supervillains
regardless I think we can all agree that
whoever signed off on Green Lantern is
clearly been on the ruination of mankind
even if they don't have a secret
underground volcano lair
there I said it now it's your turn what
do you think about the way Hollywood has
gone soft on supervillains do you think
it's really possible to rehabilitate
baddies let me know in the comments and
make sure you subscribe